il est grand temps maintenant pour nous
d'oser nous montrer comment on le fait
aujourd'hui pour que d'autres se
l'autorisent on ne peut plus cautionner
le silence c'est fini le silence on en
peut plus du silence comment voulez-vous
que les clients comprennent ce qui est
en train de se passer si on reste dans
le silence ça n'est pas possible
voilà
voilà pour ouvrir ce 7 8 sociétés de ce
soir vous venez d'entendre une phrase
forte et signée de Laurence et une des
représentantes du mouvement français des
survivants de la prostitution et cet
extrait d'un documentaire que vous avez
réalisé lors du bois bonsoir merci
d'être en plateau avec nous
Laurence et puis Rosen c'est les deux
femmes que vous avez suivi elles sont
allés défendre leur cause auprès de
Najat Vallaud-Belkacem la ministre des
Droits des Femmes et justement nous
allons parler dans ce circuit de société
de la prostitution une loi a été votée
le 4 décembre dernier qui notamment
pénalise les clients des prostituées
1500 euros d'amende alors faut-il
fallait-il une loi pour pénaliser la
prostitution la loi va-t-elle assez loin
à votre avis elle va assez loin cette
loi il vient du bois alors en fait on
parle beaucoup de la pénalisation des
clients en fait non non il y a pas que
ça en fait c'est une loi dans son
ensemble qui a on pourrait dire un thème
général un axe général c'est de
reconnaître que la prostitution vécue
par les femmes est une violence donc
c'est dans cet esprit là que il y a eu
de combat qui date de qui a été menée
depuis 10 ans par des associations et
donc qui a été rejoint par des femmes
qui ont vécu la prostitution donc il y a
enfin moi j'ai suivi Laurence et Rosen
et il y en a deux ou trois autres aussi
et puis maintenant c'est un mouvement
qui est en train de s'étendre qui existe
déjà d'ailleurs beaucoup à l'étranger et
qui qui exprime justement cette
souffrance qui est vécu à l'intérieur de
la prostitution alors évidemment le
grand débat c'est cristallisé sur la
pénalisation des clients mais c'est le
quatrième volet il y a trois autres
volets qui sont très importantes dans
cette loi on en parlera
dans Lucie sabotosait le fait le
féminisme ce qui me frappe quand on
entend cet extrait de Laurence c'est le
mot honte c'est à dire que faut sortir
du silence parce que il y a honte elles
ont honte de faire le métier de
prostituée alors qu'on dit souvent que
c'est le plus ancien métier du monde
de le faire ce métier là ce que l'on dit
ce que l'on croit entendre et ce qu'on
croit savoir écouter moi je vais je vais
vous dire ça fait plus de 10 ans que je
travaille sur cette question un petit
peu par hasard parce que le premier film
que j'ai fait c'était plus sur la traite
des êtres humains donc sur les réseaux
des femmes qui étaient importées qui
encore existent énormément en ce moment
des des pays de l'Est et d'Afrique et je
me rendais pas compte que effectivement
il y avait d'une part enfin moi je
pensais comme tout le monde que la
prostitution était en général quelque
chose qui pouvait bien se passer puisque
c'était c'est ce que je pensais un
agrément entre personnes consentantes et
en fait je me suis rendu compte d'une
chose c'est que
qui se disait qu'on s'entende c'est
l'application de cette de la loi
réglementariste au Pays-Bas je me suis
rendu compte que même à l'intérieur de
ce système qui commercialise la
prostitution comme un commerce normale
les femmes une fois les portes fermées
me disaient il fallait passer du temps
pour avec elle pour avoir un peu un
autre son de cloche que de toute façon
elles avaient été formatées pour ça que
c'était une souffrance continuelle
qu'elles aient été victimes de la traite
ou non que en soi la prostitution était
une traite et donc mais c'est des
paroles qui sont très très peu audible
parce que évidemment ça arrange tout le
monde de se dire
c'est le plus vieux métier du monde et
on balaye la question pas par quelques
phrases comme ça c'était pas vraiment
posé la question mais je pense que c'est
plutôt ça c'est-à-dire que c'était
rentré dans les mœurs
de fréquenter les bordel avec ma caméra
et avec mes oreilles et d'entendre et de
voir et je pense que au fur et à mesure
je me suis forgé cette
cette opinion maintenant que
effectivement c'est la prostitution en
elle-même qui est une violence c'est une
violence mais qu'est-ce que vous
répondez notamment aux hommes parce que
cette loi sur la prostitution qui a été
votée en première lecture l'Assemblée
nationale le 4 décembre il y a eu quand
même tout un débat et il y a une
notamment ce Manifeste des 343
qui ont dit c'est cette loi est une
entrave à notre liberté individuelle
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez à ces
hommes alors du coup
je leur répond que
qu'ils sont pour dire ça qu'est-ce
qu'ils savent des femmes qu'ils disent
être consentantes qu'est-ce qu'ils en
savent quand on travaille un peu mais
c'est une question de travail et de
volonté de comprendre
quand on travaille un peu on se rend
compte que les il y a pas de femme
volontaire qu'elles sont formatées c'est
ce qu'elle dit c'est ce que disent
Laurence et Rosen que j'ai suivi elle
même Rosen elle-même donc l'autre femme
elle a cru qu'elle était volontaire elle
dit un beau jour j'avais plus rien dans
le frigo je suis j'ai répondu à une
annonce et je me suis retrouvé dans un
bar à hôtel je pensais que j'étais
consentante et libre et j'ai mis 10 ans
à me rendre compte qu'on m'avait formé
formaté pour ça et quand elle fait un
travail sur elle-même il y a un cest un
viol
contre vous la comprenez quand même
cette ce manifeste vous le comprenez ce
manifeste cette prise de position comme
ça assez forte en plus mais qui sont ces
à part le fait que ce sont des notables
de de de de des people qui mais qui sont
qu'est-ce qu'ils connaissent enfin de
cette réalité non je les comprends pas
du tout je
trouve qu'il ferait mieux de réfléchir
et travailler un peu plus sur la
question avant de c'est comme le quand
on dit également que c'est du domaine
privé c'est pas vrai le l'inceste c'est
du domaine privé le la violence
conjugales c'était le domaine privé
parce que les portes se sont fermées
c'est un à l'intérieur de la maison non
c'est un problème de société on va
continuer à parler avec vous vers du
bois Lucie va nous rejoindre dans
quelques instants je voudrais qu'on
regarde un nouvel extrait de votre
documentaire donc il s'appelle les
survivants de la prostitution dont TV
Phil sera diffuseur je l'ai pas précisé
ce sera courant du premier semestre
trimestre pardon 2014 alors on va donc
revenir sur la réalité de la position
dont je vous parlais comment cette
notion a même évolué au sein des
politiques et puis ensuite on aura par
téléphone un syndicat de police qui
partage pas votre point de vue regarde
cet extrait
j'ai entendu plusieurs femmes qui ont
connu la prostitution elles ont toutes
vécu des humiliations ou des violences
sexuelles durant leur enfance ou des
violences physiques pour moi c'était
très simple une maman qui m'a rejeté
j'ai pas connu mon père et donc j'ai
vécu avec un beau-père qui lui était pas
très très nette
brutalement nous nous sommes rendus
compte et ça a été pour nous vraiment je
vais dire une révélation que nous étions
non pas dans le domaine de
la prostituée fille de joie du 19e des
romans des Balzac de belles de jour mais
que nous étions dans ce qu'il y a de
plus sordide c'est-à-dire la violence
extrême dans laquelle vivent ces
personnes et nous avons donc
complètement inversé notre notre regard
ces personnes prostituées sont donc des
victimes et non pas des délinquants
comme la loi sécurité intérieure a voulu
leur faire jouer ce rôle elles sont dans
les mains des mafia et lorsqu'elles ne
sont pas puisqu'on ne peut pas imaginer
que toutes les femmes prostituées sont
dans les mains des mafia en toute état
de cause elle dit de situation de
violence extrême parce que l'exercice de
la prostitution est très extrêmement
violent en lui-même
bonsoir alors vous votre syndicat ne
discute pas sur le fond cette loi vous
respectez évidemment le travail des
législateurs toutefois vous vous dites
que sur le terrain ça va être difficile
à appliquer
bien évidemment une loi on sait bien que
dans ces domaines là aussi une loi
suffisait à changer un phénomène de
société tel que celui-ci ça se saurait
bien évidemment la problématique pour
les policiers aujourd'hui va être de
pouvoir procéder à des contrôles sur la
voie publique établir effectivement
l'infraction qui a été prévue par le
législateur ce qui va pas être une mince
affaire
bien évidemment et c'est moyen qu'on
mettra pendant un petit bon parce que
bien souvent un effet de un effet de
mode lorsque ce type de
bien créé on va demander aux policiers
de travailler
dessus pour produire des effets et les
efforts qui seront fait dans ce
domaine-là ne seront pas faits dans un
autre nom bien évidemment ça va ça va
compliquer le travail des policiers sur
le terrain donc compliqué le travail
est-ce que vous avez l'impression aussi
que les prostituées du coup vont être
plus se cacher que la possession va
continuer mais peut-être sous une forme
un peu plus cachée
oui tout à fait c'est le risque auquel
on s'expose aujourd'hui de créer des
réseaux un petit peu différents un petit
peu cachés de prostitution et encore une
fois mon travail des policiers a été
effectif non non ces domaines là pour
essayer de réguler l'insécurité qui peut
qui peut être occasionnée par ces
phénomènes de prostitution
de masse mais encore une fois nous
serons souhaite c'est que le maximum des
moyens soit mis pour la lutte contre les
réseaux de prostitution contre le
proxénétisme et c'est bien évident il
est bien évident que les moyens qu'on
mettra pour lutter contre les clients ne
permettrait pas de encore une fois
d'être présent dans d'autres secteurs en
général les principalement sur le
secteur de de des réseaux de
prostitution sur des fonctionnaires etc
donc ça veut dire selon vous qu'il
fallait un autre type de loi
d'autres mesures
oui
écoutez nous avec les mesures existantes
bien évidemment ça permettait d'apporter
une régulation même si tous mes journées
encore une fois je crois que pendant des
années on a accès le travail de la
police sur la politique du chiffre ce
qui a eu des effets pervers en outre un
effet pervers c'est la baisse de la
quantité des enquêtes sur encore une
fois tous
en parlant par la Constitution mais
c'est la même chose donc tout ce qui est
réseau de trafic de stupéchés etc les
moyens n'ont pas été à la hauteur dans
ces domaines là donc je crois que plus
que de légiférer
le réel moyen dont tu as besoin la
police pour effectuer son travail
pouvoir lutter réellement contre la
racine du mal et non pas contre les
conséquences de celui-ci merci Stéphane
vous allez rester encore quelques
instants en ligne avec nous Lucie ça va
je vous vois au chien un peu de la tête
quand Stéphane Liévin parle qu'est-ce
que vous auriez envie de lui répondre
non mais je comprends sa perspective en
fait elle sa réaction n'est pas très
surprenante en Suède à l'époque où la
loi est passée elle était très
impopulaire elle était même peut-être
plus impopulaire qu'ici encore et il y
avait effectivement des professionnels
des forces de l'ordre qui disaient ça
c'est pas applicable ça va être
ingérable pour nous etc aujourd'hui ces
gens ont changé de regard pour bon
nombre d'entre eux et cette loi est bien
70% de la population suédoise y est
favorable je rappelle que cette loi elle
se résume pas à l'inversion de la charge
pénale néanmoins cette inversion de la
charge pénale donc remettre les choses à
l'endroit c'est-à-dire
cesser de de considérer les personnes
prostituées comme des délinquantes et
bien replacer leur parcours dans tous
les déterminismes qui amènent un certain
nombre de femmes dans la prostitution
aujourd'hui les prostituée redeviennent
des victimes tout à fait elles sont
reconnues pour ce qu'elles sont
c'est-à-dire des victimes du système
prostitueur des victimes de la demande
d'un certain nombre d'hommes une
minorité en fait de clients prostituoirs
monsieur parler de la traite comment
lutter contre la traite quand on ne
prend pas le problème à la racine la
racine c'est la demande d'un certain
nombre d'hommes leur demande elle est
aussi raciste et neocolonial pour un
certain nombre d'emplois
où on mettait en place la loi tant
qu'aux Pays-Bas et donc à l'époque
c'était très clair il y avait la bonne
prostitution et la mauvaise prostitution
on lutter contre la mauvaise c'est à
dire la traite et on a situé donc un
système pour réglementer la bonne
prostitution pour que les volontaires
soi-disant puissent travailler dans des
conditions
honorable etc et en sécurité et en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on s'aperçoit et c'est
pareil d'ailleurs en Allemagne c'est que
en fait les réseaux ont augmenté depuis
que ces réglementés pourquoi parce que
c'est un appel d'air collectivement il y
a il y a une augmentation de
la demande il n'y a pas suffisamment si
je puis dire de main d'oeuvre
excusez-moi du terme sur place de bonnes
prostituées bien de chez nous donc il y
a une importation de
clandestine par des réseaux mafieux qui
n'ont fait qu'augmenter depuis que cette
soirée lointariste a été institué donc
au Pays-Bas il y en a un match pareil
par rapport à ça je crois que pour
l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas le bilan est
vraiment atroce c'est à dire que
Monsieur parlait monsieur Liévin parlait
de de clandestinité souvent cette
question revient est-ce que ça va pas
est-ce que le la loi abolitionniste va
pas précipiter les personnes prostituées
dans la clandestinée on voit que et ben
en fait c'est pas si simple déjà la
question déjà là et le danger de toute
façon il est à partir du moment où les
personnes prostituées sont seules avec
les clients prostituées qu'elle soit
dans une chambre de luxe ou dans un bois
ou dans une camionnette ça il faut
remettre les choses quand même en place
Stéphane Eva vous voulez répondre à
Lucie sabot elle pense que non pas du
tout ça va pas créer de clandestinités
en Allemagne et aux Pays-Bas il y a que
40 personnes prostituées déclarées en
Allemagne
dire que tout le monde est d'accord pour
pour lutter contre la prostitution entre
guillemets non volontaire et contre ces
filles de l'Est pousser la prostitution
par des réseaux bien évidemment tout le
monde est d'accord sur le sujet
simplement si on veut lutter contre
contre la demande je crois que cela
demande entre guillemets pour reprendre
une expression bien connue et comme le
monde je crois que la demande serait
organisera en fonction de la législation
et la nature ayant horreur du vide il me
semble que que ça développera les
réseaux clandestins maintenant si
effectivement cette loi peut permettre
de dépenser
assistance à des prostituées en
difficulté au sein de réseau au sein
desquels elles sont elles sont
persécutées bien évidemment ce sera ça
ne pourra être positif s'il y a des
expériences étrangères qui ont montré
que
les systèmes permettaient effectivement
de lutter contre ce type de prostitution
là allons-y simplement pour les
policiers de terrain je reviens à ça
parce que pour une vitesse d'effet de
police force ouvert un syndicat
majoritaire de la police il s'agit de
défendre les
conditions de travail des policiers et
pour effectivement entre guillemets
faire tenir l'infraction parce que
aux questions de ça et il va être
difficile pour les policiers de d'amener
les éléments constitutifs de
l'infraction dans les procédures qui
vont être remonter voilà plus compliqué
pour les policiers on leur a bien
compris merci beaucoup Stéphane levain
d'être intervenus en direct ce soir sur
TV Phil merci donc à travailler plus
compliqué pour les policiers on a
entendu la même chose lorsqu'on a obtenu
la reconnaissance du viol comme crime
que ça allait être très compliqué de
prouver que c'est pas vrai on trouve
toujours des faisceaux d'indices et
surtout ce que je voudrais rappeler
c'est que la prostitution de personnes
mineures d'enfants d'adolescentes elle
est interdite évidemment déjà elle est
passible de 3 ans d'emprisonnement ce
qui est trop peu mais elle est très très
peu réprimée justement parce qu'il y a
pas déjà de cadre global cohérent qui
reconnaît que tout obtention par
l'argent d'un acte sexuel non désiré est
une violence si bien que lorsque les
hommes qui sont clients prostituèrent
qui sont une minorité rappelons-le
cherche à obtenir des rapports
prostitutionnels avec des personnes
mineures ils ne sont pas inquiétés dès
lors que il va y avoir petit à petit une
culture dans le sens de l'ordre d'aller
chercher d'aller repérer des clients
prostituteurs en train de commettre ces
violences-là ils vont aussi combattre la
prostitution de personnes mineures ça
c'est très important donc faire évoluer
les mentalités aussi on parlait
effectivement sur la loi vous disiez
c'est évidemment tout le monde s'est
arrêté sur l'affaire de la pénalisation
des clients mais il y a tout un volet
social d'accompagnement sans lequel
ça n'aurait en fait aucun sens de de ne
faire qu'inverser la charge pénale même
si c'est important il y a un pilier
vraiment crucial dans cette loi qui est
l'accompagnement social des personnes
prostituées il y a un fond de 20
millions d'euros pour le parcours dit de
sortie de la prostitution il s'agit avec
cette loi de donner vraiment pleinement
le droit à toutes les femmes de ne pas
être prostituées parce que il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui pas pleinement le
choix on parle de choix mais c'est
souvent un choix biaisé un choix
finalement complètement
dans votre documentaire vers du bois
c'est qu'on sent que les femmes elles
ont pas forcément eu largement le choix
d'être prostitué
référence à d'autres films j'ai quand
même été assez surpris en tournant ton
Pays-Bas il y a il y a 7 ans je tournais
une femme qui qui faisait la promotion
dans un centre d'information pour les
clients à Amsterdam qui montrait la
sécurité comment ça se passait etc et
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec elle à
parler avec elle
à dîner avec elle et un jour elle ferme
la porte et elle dit écoute maintenant
je vais tout te dire et elle s'effondre
et elle dit tout elle dit je n'ai eu
qu'une vie de merde et je fais la
promotion de la vie de merde que nous
avons eu
chez Laurence et Rosen qui sont les deux
femmes que vous avez su faire la
promotion de ce beau métier on va faire
une petite pause en ce 7 8 on est allé à
la rencontre on va voir que les les avis
sont quand même très partagés nous
sommes à la rencontre d'habitants et on
leur a demandé s'il fallait une loi pour
pénaliser la prostitution on va écouter
leur réponse et puis je vous ferai
réagir tout de suite après
je pense que malheureusement la
prostitution est vieille comme le monde
et que c'est quand même une question de
rapport individuel il y a déjà des lois
pour purnir les pensées nettes et je
crois qu'il faut les appliquer
férocement mais par contre punir les
clients plus dire les prostituées tout
ça ça me paraît de la faribole
complètement
idiot
parce que avant le racolage était
interdit
bon maintenant c'est le contraire donc
ils ont le droit de recoller vous faites
emmener vous prenez la prune donc c'est
n'importe quoi je suis pas d'accord du
tout sauf que les gens ont le droit
d'aller voir les prostituées c'est pas
eux d'être verbalisé pour ça et ça peut
peut-être éviter des viols sur les
jeunes filles voilà pourquoi en priorité
je suis pas d'accord
c'est un sujet compliqué j'ai pas
vraiment réfléchi à la question
je pense que ça part d'une bonne
intention à la base quand même de projet
de TGV prostituées parce que c'est la
bonne solution je sais pas on verra
l'usage ce qu'il faut pénaliser personne
parce que elles ont pas forcément le
choix il faut les protéger s'il y a des
gens qui les comme les jeunes d'Europe
de l'Est qui les font travailler mais
autrement peut-être les protéger mieux
alors peut-être je sais pas si une bonne
idée mais elle est elle est incohérente
cette fois on peut pas autoriser la
prostitution et interdire l'utilisation
de la prostitution donc c'est pour moi
c'est incohérent
de moment fort quand même ces
micro-trottoirs d'abord ce que dit cette
femme à la fin c'est incohérent on peut
pas à la fois pénaliser les clients et
puis ne pas interdire la prostitution et
puis surtout ce que dit cette femme
c'est là où je voudrais vous faire
réagir si on retire la prostitution il y
aura plus de viol c'est vraiment ce
qu'il y a un lien direct entre les deux
moi je pense que fondamentalement il y a
un manque de réflexion et d'information
en fait c'est un sujet où tout le monde
pense tout savoir effectivement c'est il
y a que des idées toutes faites qui se
qui se baladent énormément il y a pas
effectivement moins de réflexion
simplement je vais vous dire une chose
valider n'est pas de moi il y a eu un
travail qui a été fait sur sur les
clients il y a quelques années qui a été
organisé inquiéter mandaté par le nid et
un sociologue me disait quand on
réfléchit bien parce que le fond de fond
du problème c'est se dire les hommes ont
des pulsions il faut bien assouvir cette
pulsion sinon on va vers le viol dans le
dans la rue etc donc on part du principe
que les hommes ont des pulsions donc
c'est la nature qui est mal faite ou qui
est bien faite en tout cas les hommes
ont des pulsion les femmes n'en sais
rien entre par ça on n'a pas
est-ce que on s'est posé la question que
toutes les idéologies et toutes les
politiques de domination que ce soit le
racisme que ce soit le colonialisme que
ce soit le nazisme était fondé sur des
thèses naturels
comme ça donc gérons la nature l'homme a
des pulsions donc gérons c'est plus son
des hommes voilà on a des preuves
accablantes du fait que non seulement
c'est vraiment pour le coup des
fariboles de dire que l'abolition nous
précipiterait dans une société où il y
aurait encore plus de viable parce qu'il
y en a déjà beaucoup en fait et ils sont
très impunis seulement 2% des violeurs
sont condamnés
c'est faux il y a l'état du Nevada dans
lequel il y a des bordels légaux c'est
l'État au sein des États-Unis dans
lequel il y a un record absolu de viol
par ailleurs la prostitution
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est des actes
sexuels non désirés quel que soit le ce
type de prostitution considérées si
tentait que y est des types de
prostitution qu'on pourrait
compartimenter nous ce qu'on constate
c'est que en fait c'est un continuum par
ailleurs je voudrais quand même dire
quelque chose
le l'analyse abolitionniste l'analyse
féministe elle est construite à partir
de la parole de survivante moi comment
je suis devenue féministe abolitionniste
en entendant Rosa nicheur en entendant
Nathalie en entendant Laurence Noël en
entendant Rebecca Motte une survivante
britannique qui raconte en fait comment
elles ont raconté elles ont appris à
dire pendant des années j'ai choisi tout
va bien c'est un métier etc et comment
quand elles peuvent enfin en sortir mais
elles sont obligées à un moment de de
dire en fait qu'elles ont vraiment vécu
et qu'est-ce qu'elle disent elles disent
mais c'est des viole à répétition c'est
des viols à répétitions et elles mettent
des années à retrouver un petit peu
d'énergie en fait justement Lucie vous
parlez de Rosen et Laurence ce sont les
deux que vous avez suivi je voudrais
qu'on conclut cette émission justement
en leur laissant la parole c'est encore
un extrait de votre documentaire et qui
sera diffusé sur téléfiles au premier
trimestre 2014 elles ont rencontré Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem la ministre des Droits
des Femmes et voilà ce qu'elles nous ont
dit à la ministre
une chose très importante on est que
deux
il faut bien comprendre que si on vient
vous voir c'est que vraiment on fait ce
pas là qui est pour nous très difficile
aussi parce qu'il faut s'affranchir de
sa propre honte mais on le fait surtout
il faut savoir qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
restent dans le silence
toutes les deux vous auriez dit que vous
étiez consentante
mais oui mais moi je l'ai dit pendant 22
ans je disais bah oui
c'est ma liberté mais en fait je n'étais
pas libre mon corps n'appartenait pas
pourquoi est-ce que vous vous êtes mise
à parler parce que elles sont rares
celles qui parlent en fait vous voulez
mais au moins ça va servir à ça je peux
mourir sereine j'ai perdu ma mère en
2006 et je regardais ce corps de femme
qui était ma mère que j'aimais
et j'ai envie
et chose bizarre on vient
la mort de quelqu'un
et pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'était ma
propre mort que je souhaitais
les mots sont forts il y a pas grand
chose d'autre à dire en tout cas pour
ceux qui auraient des doutes sur
fallait-il une loi pour pénaliser la
prostitution juste en 10 secondes quand
vous entendez ça vous lendemain je suis
très ému je les connais et c'est des
héroïnes je crois qu'elles sont
magnifiques alors là on les voit parler
de choses extrêmement
âpres au quotidien elle elle
construisent beaucoup de choses pour que
toutes les femmes puissent puissent
dénoncer les agresseurs que ce soit des
clients prositeurs des violeurs des
hommes qui cognent femmes et enfants etc
elle se battent vraiment pour
l'éradication du système de la
prostitution merci à vous donner d'être
venu en plateau merci merci à vous faire
du bois
il y a encore un passage
au Sénat merci beaucoup à vous deux en
tout cas ce cette petite société est
terminée pour cette année 2013 et bien
je vous donne rendez-vous l'année
prochaine pour évoquer d'autres thèmes
de société et d'ici là je vous souhaite
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année